[Music]
what do we know about godzilla's
evolving powers
of course we have seen the g-man fire
his atomic breath his nuclear pulses
which are a rare sight to see and even
the powerful spiral heat rays but
there's one thing about godzilla that we
hardly pay attention to
the king of the monsters has quite a few
origin stories but each of them revolve
around one thing a hyper evolution
factor or
also a hyper-mutation capability that
allows him to transform himself to suit
the conditions he is in and to become
more powerful over time
how and why does godzilla keep on
evolving let's talk about this here all
the versions that have this strange and
unique power
so let's get to it
firstly let's start with shin godzilla's
five forms or rather eight forms as was
theorized to have happen to him if he
survives the battle in tokyo
godzilla's appearance changed multiple
times throughout the film his first
visible change is the transition from
his first to his second form where he
changes his stance and appearance the
first form was kind of like a moving
tale and nothing else was known about it
but the second form showed a more
lizard-like appearance that crawled and
was kind of clumsy on lan then we see
the third form which was more erect and
the fourth form where he looked more
like the classic godzilla shin was the
embodiment of evolution and also of a
biological arms race with other species
so over the course of a couple of days
godzilla's hyper evolution changed him
from a moving tale to a creepy crawly
into a classic erect stunning godzilla
while at the end of the movie he further
evolved spawns of himself that are
humanoid in appearance and was smaller
to cope with the multiple threats that
he was facing that is the self-defense
forces of japan
strategically it makes sense as the big
fourth form was a very easy target and a
swarm like humanoid forms would have
been more agile and gone around the city
to destroy all resistance in a faster
way
that's evolution in light speed mode
transitioning from a singular being into
a swarm species that have a better
chance of survival as they always say
two heads are better than one and a
swarm is even more effective
this type of evolution emphasized more
on numbers than on size
godzilla also could physically shift his
body and method of attack based on his
aggressors as well as a personal need as
depicted in the movie for example he
acquired his mouth and dorsal base rays
when humanity's troops successfully
attacked from above with bunker busters
that was the evolution of a ranged
attack to counter faraway targets the
atomic breath godzilla's ability to
shoot his atomic breath from his tail
allowed him pinpoint accuracy while the
spinal rays were for cluster defense
unlike his initial usage he was also
able to do it without expending his
energy or requiring a period of rest
implying that he had evolved to spend
less energy and fight longer for
survival
shin godzilla would have continued to
evolve to counter any incoming threat to
his survival he would have had the
ability of flight with wings and
ultimately becoming a cosmic monster in
the end as theorized in the concept
so next let's look at another version of
the king of the monsters and that is his
anime version godzilla singular point
which also had four forms in total this
iteration of him was quite different
from origin to his final defeat
godzilla in his show was born out of a
trans-dimensional material called the
archetype actually he had been in
existence for millennia as he had
interacted with people in the past and
there was a skeleton of him
his previous self hidden in a vault
so godzilla in this series a closely
followed the same principle of
hyper-evolution as that of shin's
version but here the evolution factor
wasn't his cells
but the archetype interdimensional
molecule that he over time learned to
control and manipulate
in the show he first appeared in 2030 as
an aquatic monster dub as a quarterless
he was first seen 900 meters below the
sea and then later in the same form
chasing a group of mantas which were
headed inland for some reason
after a fight with one of them he
quickly realized that he needed to
change his body quickly in order to suit
with the terrestrial environment he then
became amphibia which although better
suited to live on land was still slow
and clumsy this led him to further
evolve into terrestrials which looks
like a gigantic theropod dinosaur
godzilla expels massive amount of
archetype form his skin in the form of a
crimson dust in all of his four forms
forming a dense cloud around him
and what that is is up to debate but we
can clearly see the red dust being used
as some sort of a terraforming element
as well as a substance to further his
evolution into the perfect life form
designed to survive anything in the
world any threat that he would face
the same as shin this godzilla also
evolves defense mechanisms as well as
attack powers to further his ability to
survive and be dominant
for instance amphibia can breathe a
flammable vapor that is minus 20 degrees
celsius that if ignited the vapor
creates a massive explosion about 500
meters tall
following that he freezes in place his
skin becomes a charcoal black in color
it is stated that in this form it is
just a temporary effect like a chrysalis
in order to protect himself from the
outside environment another example is
terrestris after being hit by bombs
immediately reconfigures the red dust
archetype around him to form some sort
of blood tentacles in order to protect
himself from second rounds of bombs
headed his way they actually became
tentacles and grabbed one of the bombs
mid-air
in the fourth form ultima
it also showed a couple of evolutionary
characteristics
one is his skin becoming super durable
being able to withstand any form of
conventional weaponry as his body has
learned the effect of explosions and how
to counteract them
second is his size he was 45 meters tall
at the start and then at the end he grew
to be a hundred meters tall even his
atomic breath shows his adaptive
behavior and ranged attacks at first his
atomic breath was kind of like a halo
that the third form terrestrials created
and although it was weak it could still
kill a black rodan coming its way the
atomic breath also increased in power
with the fourth form
in his first display then progressively
when he fought off the manda and lastly
when he was fighting off jet jaguar
now let's look at the monsterverse
godzilla how his evolutionary ability
helped him along in the fight against
other titans as well as retaining the
alpha status here in this version we
have nature's benign protector the one
who maintains order embodied in titanus
gojira but how did he become this and
how he changed over time is why we're
here to discuss in the eevee legends of
the novelization it was said that gojira
was like any normal titan but he ate a
hollow earth power souls which they said
it was a star and evolved into something
greater one that was capable of shooting
rays of the star from his mouth which is
the atomic breath
this also gave him the ability to grow
in size as well as change his dorsal
plates after they had shattered in the
fight against demuto prime in 2014
although most of us godzilla didn't show
any fast signs of mutation or
transformation
the changes he had in size power of his
atomic breath and dorsal plates were all
because of his nature to transform into
a more powerful version in order to deal
with more dangerous threats around him
that is evolution or
rather the biological arms race between
species in science it is called the red
queen hypothesis
what is this well the red queen
hypothesis is a theory in evolutionary
biology proposed in 1973
that species must constantly adapt
evolve and proliferate in order to
survive while pitted against ever
evolving opposing forces for example a
number of predator-slash-prey species
couples compete via running speed the
rabbit runs faster than the fox because
the rabbit is running for his life
while the fox needs to run faster in
order to catch his dinner
each species keeps on evolving to run
faster than the other
okay let's get back to godzilla lastly
we have heisei godzilla's hyper-mutated
g-cells and their properties which were
core to the birth of two other kaiju in
a 1989 movie geneticist shiragami
creates a human slash rose hybrid
biollante by combining the dna of its
deceased daughter along with a rose bush
and the g cells of godzilla
in the 1994 film it was thought that the
g-cells from biollante or carried out by
mothra to space may have fell into a
black hole and came out through a white
hole and were exposed to lots of energy
sources and because of this the cells
may have evolved creating the space
creature called space godzilla
even orga started out as a squid monster
kaiju called millennium and then became
the master he is after absorbing
godzilla's g-cells this shows that the
g-cells are hypermutative and
hyper-evolving
the other instances like zilla's
mutation origin from a marine iguana and
shower dinosaur origin the
godzillasaurus were all rapid mutations
caused by nuclear weapons and not in it
within him and also within the same
version there was no other further
evolutions that took place even godzilla
earth took 20 000 years to grow in size
so let's leave them out and with that we
come to the end of the video so do hit
that like button for support and
subscribe as well to be a part of the
mind cue family but most of all smash
that bell icon for regular updates on
new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam